this video sponsored by squarespace the
best way to make an amazing website the
z16 that i just reviewed is an extremely
fast laptop paired with intel's 10
nanometer 55w chips but in that review
you guys said that even though it
doesn't really compare with the m1 air
you guys still want to see how it stacks
up especially when we go ahead and
unplug the cable how they can perform so
today let's go ahead and do that so this
is an extremely unfair comparison
obviously on one end we have a two
thousand seven hundred dollar machine
and on the other end we have a machine
that's uh msrp at a thousand bucks but
you can pick it up for a lot lower the
lowest i've seen is 850. on one end this
thing that's fans are spinning up right
now and we're gonna talk about that just
sitting here plugged in and then we have
a completely fanless machine we also
have 32 gigs of ultra fast ram compared
to just eight gigs and then we have four
high performance cores compared to eight
high performance cores and a dedicated
graphics card compared to the built-in
uh seven core in this case the base
model and one graphics chip so this is
completely
shouldn't be happening but we're doing
it for you guys you guys want to see it
as we're waiting for the m1x chips we
will just do this and then when that
comes out maybe we'll have to revisit
this and by the way as you guys see we
have brand new merch available with this
m1x design with the circuitry coming
through that vadim made so if you guys
want to get one of these you guys want
to support the channel go ahead and
check it out down below let's start out
with geekbench i'm going to go ahead and
click run as you guys could see we have
that i7 11 800 h processor with 18 cores
at 10 nanometers that run up to 4.6
gigahertz whereas the m1 goes up to 3.2
so lower frequency looks like the m1
finished this maybe about 20 seconds or
so quicker
let's see the scores on here wow okay
this is actually better than i got
before for my review as you guys see as
far as multi-core we have
8081
compared to 7620
still fairly close but the intel
processor does win and as far as single
core we're looking at 1567 compared to
1720. that means that the z16 is about
six percent faster in terms of
multi-core but the m1 is nine percent
faster in terms of single core
performance now this is actually the
closest that i've seen a different
machine be to an m1 processor now the
crazy thing is it took intel going to 10
nanometers and having a higher wattage
processor much higher in order to pull
this off but now what i want to do is
unplug this and we're going to run this
test one more time of course the macbook
air it was unplugged the whole time so
let's see what performance we get when
we don't have that extra power and as
we're waiting for this to finish let me
give a shout out to the sponsor of this
video squarespace if you've been
thinking about making your own website
squarespace is seriously the best way to
go you can build a great looking website
like we did with literally no waymaking
experience it doesn't matter if you want
a portfolio a blog e-commerce or
anything else you just simply choose a
template and customize blocks of text
and images and easily move them around
it's incredibly simple affordable and
ours have been running flawlessly for
over three years bringing in tons of
traffic thanks to its built-in seo tools
start your free two-week trial with no
credit card required by going to
squarespace.com maxtec or by using our
custom link down below and when you're
ready to launch you will save 10 off
your first purchase of a website or
domain all right we have a result and it
looks like the multi-core score dropped
and now it's pretty much identical it
went from over 8 000 and we basically
have a difference of four points which
is negligible it's identical and that's
actually good i've seen a lot of these
intel laptops where the performance
drops significantly when you unplug it
now on the single core side now instead
of having a difference of about nine
percent we have a 20 difference in
performance now next i'm gonna go to
speedometer 2.0 this is a web browsing
benchmark as you guys know the m1s are
extremely responsive because that single
core performance opening apps only using
finder using web browsers it's
incredibly quick so let's see what we
get here we go
we do have a pretty significant
difference now this thing's at basically
160 compared to 220 that's a difference
of about 38
not to say that this intel machine is
slow it's still very snappy but when we
had it plugged in it actually scored 190
which was by far the fastest i've seen
in any machine other than an m1 now
before we bust out the thermal camera
and do a thermal throttling test
let's go ahead and talk about graphics
performance obviously with the z16 we
have that rtx 3060 graphics card it is a
beast and then on the m1 we have apple's
slowest ever apple silicon graphics that
they're ever gonna make this is the
seven core base model so let's go ahead
here i'm gonna switch over to cuda from
opencl and then we're gonna use metal on
the m1 and let's see how our graphics
cards perform all right guys well this
is a huge difference we have 94 000
compared to 19 000. that is literally
five times the graphics performance
pretty significant now of course when we
go and we unplug the laptop i'm going to
go ahead and run that again it is going
to go down but surprisingly it doesn't
go down that much here we go it looks
like we have a difference of about 12 13
that is what we had as far as loss when
we unplugged now that is actually really
impressive because that chip the
graphics ship in here uses a lot of
wattage and in previous laptops we
actually saw massive drops with the
quadro p5000 i think it went all the way
from like 90 something thousand down to
about 35. it was insane but this
performance is still really good now my
main question is when we compare when we
can take this performance and we add in
the cpu performance and we actually do
real world work will we still maintain
this level performance or are both of
those things running at the same time
going to throttle it much more we will
see in just a second but next let's go
ahead and talk about thermal throttling
and cpu performance i'm going to go
ahead and open up cinebench and i
mentioned that this is a ultra fast
laptop
but with that performance because of the
wattage this thing does get loud we'll
see let's go ahead and get a baseline
reading as you guys could see where
you're looking at about 37 celsius there
at the hottest spot this thing has a
really impressive cooling system and
scooting over to our m1
31 degrees celsius remember this has no
cooling system we used to have thermal
pads in here we did that mod that gave
it a lot more performance but we got rid
of that so this is in stock form like a
drop down to 30. so definitely the m1
chip is very efficient we'll see how
these heat up in just a little bit now i
already ran this test for the review
with it plugged in so this time i'm
going to go ahead and unplug it and
right off the bat bam we're hitting 45
watts so it looks like instead of
peaking at 55 it is limiting it down to
45 as far as clock speeds wow okay that
is a lot lower 2
100 2.2 gigahertz that's crazy that is a
huge limitation we're just running about
a 65 degree celsius that's way cool
previously it would just hit 97 90
degrees right away as you guys could see
by this screenshot wow guys look at that
we're now sitting at 25 watts so look at
this we have an hour and 34 minutes
remaining as far as battery life when
we're maxing out the cpu now that is
normal i guess that's to be expected but
it's interesting because
this macbook pro when you're doing heavy
work like this or the macbook air in
this instance it will still last for
about three and a half hours compared to
one and a half so way better battery
life on the plus side the fans although
they're on they are much quieter than
they were previously
and that's because the temps are very
low we're under 70 degrees so what i'm
gonna do is i'm actually gonna stop this
i'm gonna run it just one time to see
the score and then we'll do it plugged
in to look at the thermals all right
look at that that is actually surprising
we have a score of
8833 now that is lower than the full
performance score
but over here with the m1 we have 6700
now the m1 air we get about a thousand
less than the m1 mac mini that has a
good fan so definitely losing
performance because of thermal
throttling but we're still getting
better performance here even though it
was running at such a low clock speed
about 2.2 2.3 gigahertz and 25 watts so
let's go ahead and plug this thing back
in and i'm gonna go ahead and run that
10 minute throttle test and we'll see
how this thing heats up right off the
bat you guys may hear those fans
spinning up uh we do know denoise this
audio so i don't know how you'll hear it
but it is loud it's significant we're
almost at 90 degrees celsius
right right away 55 watts so even though
these are 10 nanometers they still suck
a lot of power if you let them bam it's
at 94 95 degrees celsius now and look at
some of those cores they're throttling
down in order to get the system to cool
down a bit all right so it's been just
over five minutes uh temps have settled
in around 91 92 degrees celsius three
gigahertz and look at the temps here
we're looking at 46.47
and this is with fans exhausting
everything now on the m1 we're looking
at 40 degrees in one hot spot without a
fan so that is just getting heat soaked
the the temps aren't really going
anywhere so definitely a lot hotter with
this intel processor just because it's
more efficient doesn't mean it doesn't
get hot and on the top and you feel
how dang hot it is when i was
benchmarking the system
i lifted it up the desk and the desk was
super hot it was crazy now as far as mac
cpu performance with msi plugged in it
gets about 48 more performance than the
m1 chip that is thermal throttled in the
m1 macbook air so that is a pretty
significant difference and now let's see
how all this adds up in the real world
this is lightroom classic it is very cpu
intensive and the z16 is incredibly fast
at lightroom one of the fastest machines
switching between photos is super quick
even though i have tons of effects on
these raw images faster than the m1 as
you guys see we have a little bit more
of a delay here
but that is at least on battery power
i've also exported some images here and
then it was insanely fast a part of
that's also the 32 gigabytes of memory
but i want to see what happens when we
end up unplugging it as well
so now
okay look at that it's still super quick
of course our single core performance
did go down let's see how that compares
to here
still does seem a little bit faster or
maybe similar it did slow down a tiny
bit before it was almost instant now as
far as brushes it was also incredible so
i'm gonna go into the brush i'll set it
to adjust for exposure let's see if we
get some lag like we do on the m1
so right there at the start
a little bit but definitely better so it
still performs great on battery power
and now let's go ahead and export these
images i already know that the z16 is
insanely fast plugged in let's see what
it gets unplugged all right this is
interesting so it looks like as far as
speed
they are close um so the m1 is keeping
up at this point
but the fans keep ramming up on this
thing that was probably my biggest
complaint not only do they get loud if
you have it plugged in
but now when we're doing a real workload
we're working the graphics and we're
working the cpu the fans are just
modulating up and down and up and down
even unplugged when we're using way less
power meaning way less heat oh wow this
thing is just shot out like an arrow it
was going slow at first now it is just
flying about to finish this test where
we are still waiting here on the m1 all
right guys this is impressive
the macbook air took three minutes and
six seconds which is great especially
for eight gigs of ram that is actually
the limitation with this system maybe
faster than 16. now here we have 32 gigs
of ram but this time we unplugged it
when we had it plugged in it took a
minute and 59 seconds so just under two
minutes but unplugged it took two
minutes and one second so for this task
it literally did not slow down being
unplugged which is amazing that is
fantastic that's really really good
performance uh but you guys let me know
down below is it worth spending a lot
more having a much louder much heavier
machine to go from two minutes you know
from three minutes down to two minutes i
guess it maybe depends on how much you
do this but i want to hear your guys's
thoughts now next let's go ahead and
shut down lightroom and we're gonna do a
little bit of video editing now there is
no doubt that the z16 is the better
video editing machine it has that much
more powerful rtx graphics card now here
they are both playing back this timeline
perfectly let me go over here to the
edit screen and the
for the money is insane as far as its
performance but the difference is how
much overhead we have so here i have a
couple let's apply that film grain we're
looking at 61
c gpu usage here which they've actually
optimized that is really good so you
still have overhead for more effects
whereas with the z16 and that rtx
graphics card if we take a look at it
looks like we have 34 40 usage so we
have more overhead but not as much as we
expected now one thing that's
interesting is if we go ahead and plug
this thing in
then we have more juice to the graphics
card and then the usage should actually
go down so right there you guys see now
we're only at 16 graphics usage with the
same thing happening in the background
it's just more power gives it extra
performance so now we're looking at 16
20
compared to 60. now both of these
graphics chips apples and nvidia's have
really really fast encoding so when
you're exporting a video it is insanely
fast especially with h.265 so let's go
ahead and export this all right wow
right off the bat here we're looking at
two minutes and 35 seconds oh it's going
up three minutes now
here we have a minute and 10 seconds
remaining so this is where you start
running into some throttling when the
cpu is being used the graphics is being
used and you don't have enough power
okay we're at four minutes now so it's
just slowing down and if you guys can
see that tiny number there it's
rendering at about 15 frames per second
here we're at 86.5 87. that's a massive
difference all right guys we're almost
done here three two one
bam a minute and 24 seconds for a five
minute project with effects not in final
cut this davinci resolve it's insanely
fast now here
five minutes 14 seconds remaining so
it's already been a minute and a half
and now it's starting to slowly go down
it leveled out that's a massive
difference uh if you're video editing on
the go definitely the m1 air kills and
of course it's way less expensive now
when we plug it in it actually took a
minute and 54 seconds so it's still
slower at exporting but of course you
have more overhead if you have extra
effects if you have tougher footage so
i'm just going to stop this i'm not
going to wait this is about a seven
minute export here compared to a minute
24 and i'm not saying that the m1 air is
better for video editing if you have it
plugged in you're doing heavier stuff
yes this machine is better you have more
graphics performance but for most people
the kind of work that most people do the
m1 air is just such an incredible value
and obviously on the go you're getting
this killer performance
and way better battery life cheaper
lighter weight it's an awesome machine
now of course me personally i'm waiting
for the m1x that's what we want and this
is going to be interesting when we get
that extra graphics performance we get
extra ram availability what will a
comparison like this look like when
you're looking at intel's best about
five years six years late now for a full
you know 45 watt 10 nanometer chip
compared to apple's um you know new m1x
processor that is going to be incredible
so you guys let me know your thoughts um
hit that little subscribe button above
you guys can help us reach a million
subscribers we would love that check out
one of those great videos over there you
guys can check out the review of this
machine this has been max and i'll see
you in the next video
[Music]
you